В ефірі «heute journal»
з Ханною Ціммерман і Крістіаном Зіверсом.
Добрий вечір! Сьогодні нам терміново
потрібно глянути на дуже велику картину -
картину  нашого світу,
в якому останнім часом так багато змін.
Це пов'язано не лише з пандемією і війною,
хоча слово «лише» у цьому контексті
звучить невиправдано мізерно.
Але йдеться і про занепокоєння
щодо можливих масштабів голоду, яких не було десятиліттями,
боротьбу за розподіл ресурсів та
надзвичайні ситуації в енергетиці.
Йдеться про зруйновану довіру
та зруйновані ланцюжки поставок.
Йдеться про старі залежності,
які проявилися повною мірою,
та про нові, які наразі з'являються.
До цього всього доєднуються виклики
щодо порятунку клімату.
Точніше кажучи, ці виклики з'явилися не зараз,
вони існують давно і нікуди не поділися.
Наразі до них часто ставляться
як до другорядного питання,
але без цієї планети, на якій ми можемо жити,
все інше втрачає значення.
Очевидно, Ви затамували подих
і зараз видихніть.
Так, ми боїмося ризиків, але припускаємо,
що є шанси і рішення.
Сьогодні самопроголошена еліта цього світу
збирається на Всесвітній економічний форум.
Впливові, багаті, ті, хто визначає подальший курс,
а також ті, хто ухвалює невірні рішення.
Попереду багато роботи.
З Давосу - Анна Ґеллінек.
Цього разу в Давосі все інакше.
Замість морозу, снігу і в шубах
еліта від бізнесу, політики та суспільства зустрічається
серед зелені раннього літа.
Після 2,5 років пандемії,
яка стала і перервою на роздуми.
Проведення Всесвітнього економічного форуму в травні
створює нові проблеми для безпеки:
відкрито більше під'їзних шляхів,
земля біля озера не замерзла
і тому занадто м'яка для вертолітного майданчика.
Гелікоптери босів компаній-мільярдерів повинні
шукати інші місця для приземлення.
Те, як сюди діставатимуться учасники Форуму,
цілком їхня справа.
Звичайно, ми сподіваємося,
що багато хто скористається
громадським транспортом, передусім потягом.
Ми також пропонуємо трансфер з аеропорту до Давосу.
Складнішою за доїзд є ситуація у світі,
яка повністю змінилася.
Війна Росії в Україні змусила організаторів Форуму
відмовитись від запрошення всієї російської делегації.
«Російський дім» (Russia House), який останніми роками
був офіційним майданчиком
представників Росії в Давосі, тепер перейменували на
«Будинок російських воєнних злочинів».
Друга найбагатша людина України, київський олігарх,
орендує дорогу нерухомість на центральній вулиці Давосу
та фінансує виставку,
яка має показати усі жахіття війни.
Давос - це місце,
де збираються усі впливові люди,
тому вкрай важливо, щоб у місці,
де ці люди обмірковують майбутнє світу,
вони дізнавалися про те, що відбувається в Україні,
тому що частина цього майбутнього
вирішується зараз в Україні.
Менше блиску, більше вдумливості.
Жодного росіянина, лише кілька представників Китаю.
Їх мало через коронавірус, але і тому,
що Китай продовжує відокремлюватися від Заходу.
«Зменшений» форум зі згасаючою впевненістю.
Чи працює взагалі глобалізація?
Світ розколюється
на ворожі економічні блоки.
Ланцюги постачань розриваються.
Давос хоче подумати над цими питаннями,
не впадаючи у паніку.
Геополітична напруженість зараз, звичайно, вища,
ніж у попередні роки.
Компанії повинні аналізувати ситуацію,
щоб впоратися з нею та продовжувати вести бізнес.
Заробляти гроші і одночасно захищати цінності,
підтримувати відкритість ринків і захищати клімат.
Непевність у колах економічної еліти, яка на 4 дні
усамітнилася в горах Швейцарії
і якій треба дещо з'ясувати для себе.
Людина, яка започаткувала і проводить зустрічі
для усього світу в горах Швейцарії - Клаус Шваб.
Людина з адресною книгою,
яку багато хто теж хотів би мати,
тому що в ній, ймовірно,
є прямі номери мобільних телефонів
найважливіших осіб, які приймають рішення
у політиці та бізнесі по всьому світу.
Пане Шваб, добрий вечір.
Добрий вечір, пане Зіверс.
Стільки всього потрібно обговорити
і насамперед ﻿такі важливі речі.
Давайте, мабуть, почнемо з того,
як Ви оцінюєте ситуацію у світі,
а потім поговоримо про те, що обговорювалося
і пропагувалося у Давосі в минулому.
Як часто Вам доводиться зараз розмірковувати
принципово по-новому?
Я думаю, що ми вперше стикаємося з ситуацією,
коли нам доводиться вирішувати
різні небезпечні для життя кризи
разом і усі одночасно.
До цього належить, звісно, ​​і війна в Україні,
і світова економіка із загрозою голоду,
і перехід від пандемії коронавірусу
до нормального життя.
І, нарешті, не варто забувати про
нагальні кліматичні проблеми,
які потребують негайного вирішення.
Дуже, дуже багато питань, великі виклики.
У минулому ми завжди відзначали
глобалізацію світу,
зокрема й у Вас, у Давосі.
Але ми вже бачили, до чого призводять
залежності у глобалізованому світі.
Енергетична залежність, залежність від ринків збуту -
відповідно ключове слово «Росія»
і ключове слово «Китай».
Чи може наша економічна система
справді здолати всі ці випробування?
Чи тоді щось має змінитись істотно?
Чи це «дедалі більше» - дедалі більше обороту,
дедалі більше прибутку - продовжується?
Я прихильник так званого
«капіталізму зацікавлених сторін».
Це означає, що компанія повинна не лише
служити своїм акціонерам,
а й дбати про навколишнє середовище
та завжди пам'ятати про людей.
Ця мета існуватиме і надалі.
У світі, який стає дедалі фрагментованішим,
я бачу ще більшу важливість такої платформи, яку
ми маємо між політикою та бізнесом.
Ця платформа - неформальна,
але водночас користується довірою усіх залучених сторін
і безпосередньо вирішує гострі проблеми.
Але, якщо ми залишимося при думці,
що цей світ живе за межами своїх ресурсів
і насправді має величезні проблеми,
зрештою, саме через це, то чи не забагато ми
вимагаємо від керівників у Давосі,
щоб вони переосмислили ситуацію?
Ні, я думаю, що ми маємо справу із системною кризою.
І компанії, і політики, і громадянське суспільство
мають зробити свій внесок.
Немає універсального вирішення усіх проблем.
Ми повинні працювати в невеликих масштабах,
кожен із нас окремо, щоб полагодити систему.
Кожен повинен реагувати на виклики.
І те, що ми робимо в Давосі, -
це створення необхідних платформ
для спільної роботи, а також для того,
щоб донести кожному, що потрібно зробити у ситуації,
коли ми зіштовхуємося
з такою кількістю проблем одночасно.
Пане Шваб, Ви зараз дуже часто говорите про співпрацю.
Але особливо під час пандемії ми побачили,
що глобальної солідарності мало і
що у цій великій кризі кожен думав швидше про себе.
Так і є.
Пандемія зробила всіх нас егоїстичнішими,
а держави  - більш націоналістичними,
але ми, як і раніше, маємо спільні інтереси.
Насамперед подумаймо про довкілля,
про кращу підготовку
до наступної пандемії.
Тут ми потребуємо глобальної співпраці.
Тут нам потрібна платформа, і це те, для чого вона створена
і те, що ми намагаємось зробити.
Ви згадали довкілля.
Зараз ми раптом почали розглядати
наслідки війни і захист клімату як протилежності
відповідно до девізу:
спочатку потрібно розібратися з одним,
а потім можна братися за інше.
Ми бачимо міністра від Зелених,
який будує газові термінали.
У вчорашньому випуску ми розповідали про Австралію,
яка продає своє вугілля за найвищими цінами
і хоче видобувати його дедалі більше.
Як тепер зібрати все разом?
І швидко.
Так і є.
Але ми не повинні боротися з кризами одна за одною.
Ми маємо робити це одночасно.
Я знаю, що це дуже важко і
знаю, що декого це приголомшує.
Але, якщо ми цього не зробимо,
якщо ми, наприклад,
зачекаємо із вирішенням усіх екологічних проблем,
тоді ми заплатимо набагато вищу ціну,
щоб досягти вирішення проблеми.
Чи бачите Ви когось у Давосі
з усіх могутніх і впливових людей,
яких Ви там приймаєте, хто міг би запропонувати
справді життєздатне рішення?
Я думаю, що рішення знаходиться
спільними зусиллями через діалог, тому
ми зібрали всіх авторитетних діячів,
які беруть участь у боротьбі з кліматичною кризою.
Китай, США... Попри розбіжності.
І, звичайно, ми сподіваємося, що ці обговорення
матимуть певні результати.
Пане Шваб, глава Форуму сказав,
що справи у нас гірше, ніж минулого року,
але краще, ніж наступного.
Ви щодо цього більш оптимістичні?
Я більш обережний.
Я б сказав, що наступного року може бути гірше,
якщо ми не візьмемо на себе відповідальності.
І відповідальність лежить не лише на політиці,
підприємствах чи громадянському суспільстві -
всі ми маємо докласти
необхідних зусиль.
У кліматичному секторі, наприклад,
це означає не лише вимагати від компаній
стати кліматично нейтральними.
Це також означає зміни у нашому способі життя.
Це потребує інновацій.
І перевага нашої роботи полягає у тому,
що ми розглядаємо це питання цілісно
і намагаємося узгодити між собою
всі компоненти.
Нам цікаво побачити, що з цього вийде.
Клаус Шваб, дуже дякую.
Дякую, пане Зіверс.
Розмова була записана перед ефіром.
Ми багато говорили про людей.
І справді, нині ми, люди,
вже використовуємо три чверті Землі
чи зловживаємо нею у своїх цілях.
Наслідок - мільйон видів тварин і рослин
знаходяться на межі вимирання.
І не лише сьогодні, у Міжнародний день
біологічного різноманіття, потрібно сказати:
без флори та фауни немає життя.
Фабіан Кьолер.
Життя повертається в Лоддеріц Форст,
відновлений заплавний ліс.
Екологи та державні органи працюють над цим
уже 18 років,
вклавши близько 28 млн євро.
Зараз повернулися багато тварин і комах,
які тут, ﻿в Саксонії-Анґальт, тривалий час не жили.
Середовище існування підходить саме
певним видам,
а також біотопам, які таким чином зберігаються
і будуть доступні наступним поколінням.
Дослідники кажуть,
що щодня вимирають 150 видів.
Всюди скорочуються площі природних ареалів.
Світова площа лісів становить лише 68%
порівняно з доіндустріальною епохою.
3/4 території планети
змінені під впливом діяльності людини.
Численні дивовижні види тварин борються
за виживання,
наприклад, африканський лісовий слон.
Протягом 31 року його чисельність
скоротилася на 86%.
Видова криза, в якій ми перебуваємо -
це довгострокова, глобальна,
екзистенційна криза людства.
Це принаймні так само небезпечно
як кліматична криза,
якщо не небезпечніше для нас.
І тим більш прикро та загрозливо для нас,
що з моменту появи Конвенції про
біологічну різноманітність,
яка нині святкує свій сторічний ювілей,
практично нічого не змінилося на краще.
Майже всі країни три десятиліття тому запровадили
додаткові заходи щодо захисту видів.
І все ж, до мільйона видів знаходяться під
загрозою зникнення,
багато з них - у найближчі кілька десятиліть.
Вчені попереджають, закликаючи терміново
змінити тенденцію.
Якщо жаби вимиратимуть в Африці,
вони поїдатимуть менше личинок москітів.
Москіти - тварини, які щорічно вбивають
найбільше людей.
Ви вирушаєте у прекрасну Африку як турист
і заражаєтеся там малярією.
Малярія передається москітами
і те, що ми робимо в одному кінці світу,
повертається до нас в іншому.
Це стосується клімату.
Це стосується природи.
Особливо в містах і мегаполісах
знищення біорізноманіття майже непомітне.
У всьому світі збереження видів рідко займає
чільне місце
в економічному або політичному
порядку денному.
Індустріальні країни мають знову стати
ініціаторами охорони природи.
Сьогодні вже не вони, а наші моделі споживання
та виробництва призводять до зникнення видів
у всьому світі
та ﻿до надмірної експлуатації екосистем.
З точки зору аграрної політики, наприклад,
нам потрібно більше рухатися у напрямку
сталого розвитку.
Це означає: менше тваринництва,
більше рослинництва.
Або відповідним чином змінювати свою поведінку
щодо споживання.
Ми всі чудово розуміємо,
що добре для довкілля, а що - ні.
Залишилося не так багато часу, щоб щось змінити.
Наступний Всесвітній саміт з питань природи
відбудеться наприкінці серпня -
можливо, це останній шанс визначити курс.
Йдеться про тигрів і білих ведмедів,
але так само і про птахів тут, у Європі,
майже п'ята частина яких зникла з 1980 року.
Йдеться про глобальну втрату життя,
яка може стати найбільшою екологічною кризою
з часів динозаврів.
Ніхто не може сказати, що ми про це не знали.
А зараз огляд сьогоднішніх новин
з Ханною.
Почнімо з Північного Рейну-Вестфалії.
Через тиждень після виборів CDU і Зелені
оголосили про початок спільних перемовин.
Наступного тижня обидві партії хочуть обговорити
можливу урядову коаліцію,
за що висловилися комітети CDU та Зелених.
Прем'єрміністр Вюст сказав,
що тепер вони хочуть з'ясувати,
чи є міцна основа для коаліційних перемовин.
З огляду на те, що Росія продовжує атаки,
український парламент продовжив воєнний стан
ще на 90 днів.
Депутати також проголосували за продовження
загальної мобілізації.
Президент Польщі Анджей Дуда сьогодні виступив
у Верховній Раді в Києві.
Він перший з початку війни глава
іноземної держави, який це зробив.
Дуда наголосив на польсько-українській єдності
та сказав, що Польща зробить усе,
аби Україна стала членом Європейського Союзу.
Канцлер Шольц відвідав сьогодні Сенегал
як початок свого візиту до Африки.
Нині країна головує у Африканському Союзі.
У Дакарі Шольца зустрічав президент Салл.
Під час перемовин йшлося, зокрема,
про наслідки війни в Україні та співпрацю
у розробці газового родовища біля узбережжя
Західної Африки.
Сенегал сподівається на підтримку Німеччини у цьому питанні.
Наприкінці свого державного візиту
до Південної Кореї президент США Байден
відвідав спільний командний центр військ
Південної Кореї та США.
Звідти обидві країни спостерігають за розвитком
у військовій сфері Північної Кореї, зокрема ядерну загрозу.
Потім Байден вирушив до Японії,
де зустрівся з главами урядів
Японії, Індії та Австралії.
Перемовини присвячені зростаючому впливу Китаю.
В Афганістані жінки-телеведучі тепер повинні
з'являтися на екрані в повному хіджабі.
Перед камерою журналісткам віднині дозволено
показувати лише очі.
Це вказівка керівного радикального
ісламського руху «Талібан».
Прийшовши до влади минулого літа,
таліби продовжують обмежувати права жінок.
Сюди належить носіння паранджі
у громадських місцях
і заборона дівчаткам відвідувати ﻿середню школу.
Злети та падіння електорату -
частина гри для політичних партій.
І це природна частина чинної демократії.
Справжньою проблемою це стає для партії,
коли за однією невдачею у виборах слідує
інша невдача,
а потім ще одна.
Додайте до цього внутрішні суперечки
та нерозслідувані звинувачення,
а також неясність партійного напрямку,
і, врешті, з'являються заголовки з питанням:
«Партія на межі краху?»
Поговорімо про Лівих,
які спробували зібратися цими вихідними
на партійній конференції в Нижній Саксонії,
де мають бути чергові вибори.
Андреа Маурер далі.
Можливо, це сили інерції, які часто діють на Лівих.
Жанін Віслер, неблагонадійна лідерка партії,
що раніше програла, знову балотується.
Я хочу зробити внесок у те, щоб Ліві
повернули довіру і знову стали успішними.
Я вважаю, що необхідно терміново створити ﻿соціальну силу,
яка виступає за соціальну справедливість.
За спиною самої Віслер - місяці краху.
4,9% на федеральних виборах, звинувачення
у сексизмі та приховуванні інформації,
відставка її співлідерки,
значно менш ніж 5% на всіх трьох виборах
до парламентів земель.
Партія бореться за своє існування
та за свої питання.
Можливо, останній успішний Лівий Бодо Рамелов,
прем'єрміністр Тюрингії, попереджає про занепад.
Нам знову потрібне покращення діяльності,
а саме партія,
яка постає як єдине ціле,
а також працює як єдине ціле в суспільстві,
щоб виборці знали, чому вони за нас голосують.
На з'їзді партії у Тюрингії цими вихідними
Бодо Рамелов закликає до чіткої позиції,
якої мають дотримуватися всі,
й виступає проти «лівих серед лівих»,
які звинувачують НАТО у війні в Україні.
Одночасно зі з'їздом партії ці «ліві серед лівих»
організовують антинатівський конгрес,
ніби доводячи, що єдності в партії не існує.
Співініціаторами конгресу виступили депутати Бундестагу
від Лівих Севім Дагделен та Андрєй Гунько,
а також «ікона» Лівих Оскар Лафонтен,
який нещодавно вийшов із партії,
щоб продовжити чинити тиск на неї.
Це саміт тих, підтримує Путіна.
Міністерка закордонних справ Бербок
сказала, що ми маємо знищити Росію.
Це суто нацистська риторика.
Партія заявляє, що її члени не мають жодного
відношення до цього конгресу.
Однак дружина Лафонтена
Сара Ваґенкнехт вважає по-іншому.
Можна по-різному оцінювати,
чи задіяні в цьому Ліві, коли видатні
члени партії проводять конгрес.
У таборі Сари Ваґенкнехт часто кажуть,
що вона - єдиний шанс для Лівих виграти вибори.
Ваґенкнехт проводила виборчу кампанію
в Північному Рейні-Вестфалії, але це не допомогло.
Зараз вона також нарікає
на розходження думок у партії,
якому вона і сама активно сприяє.
Структура партії настільки гетерогенна,
що люди навіть не знають, чи голосують вони
за Ваґенкнехт чи за когось іншого?
За яку пропозицію, який напрямок діяльності?
Протягом найближчих днів Жанін Віслер
представить команду, з якою
вона висуває свою кандидатуру на виборах голови партії.
Інші кандидати на цю посаду,
ймовірно, будуть оголошені наступного тижня.
На доленосному з'їзді партії у червні вирішуватиметься,
якою буде партія та
чи існуватиме вона у майбутньому взагалі.
Далі Ханна про тріумф і спорт.
«РБ Лейпциг» вперше в історії клубу
виграв Кубок Німеччини з футболу.
Це, звісно, ​​масштабно відсвяткували
після повернення клубу додому.
Тисячі вболівальників зустрічали
та вітали команду на Ратгаусплатці.
І не лише там.
Після цього футболісти попрямували на автобусі
через все місто до павільйону
для масових заходів «Festwiese» на стадіоні.
Привід для святкування також має «Манчестер Сіті».
У захопливому фіналі, у матчі 38-го туру,
команда здобула
титул чемпіона англійської Прем'єрліги.
«Ліверпуль» обіграв «Вулвергемптон» з рахунком 3:1,
однак посів друге місце, тому що
«Манчестер Сіті» виграв паралельну гру
проти «Астон Вілли».
Завдяки трьом забитим голам за 5 хвилин «Манчестер Сіті»
змінив хід гри та здобув восьмий титул чемпіона.
У Формулі-1 голландець Макс Ферстаппен
виграв Гран-прі Іспанії.
В Барселоні пілот команди «Ред Булл»
Ферстаппен випередив свого партнера
по команді Серхіо Переса та
пілота «Мерседеса» Джорджа Расселла.
Чемпіон світу Ферстаппен здобув перемогу також і
завдяки невдачі його головного
суперника Шарля Леклера.
Пілот «Феррарі» лідирував,
однак зійшов з дистанції
через проблеми з двигуном.
Ферстаппен вчетверте здобув перемогу в сезоні
та захопив лідерство у чемпіонаті світу.
Посланці миру в місці, створеному для війни.
Нью-Йоркський філармонічний оркестр
на колишньому випробувальному полігоні
нацистської армії Пенемюнде.
Світова зірка Анне-Софі Муттер у залі,
що колись використовувався для
розробки зброї масово ураження.
Більший контраст навряд чи можливий.
Бернд Мозебах побував на Узедомі,
де розкупили всі квитки
не лише на концерт, а й на генеральну репетицію.
6 метрів заввишки, погляд твердо спрямований на схід -
- знак свободи, що видно здалеку,
на пляжі острова Узедом.
Вітання для Нью-Йоркського філармонічного оркестру.
Це перша поява на сцені
після півторарічної перерви через коронавірус.
Всесвітньо відомий оркестр
під керуванням головного диригента Япа ван Зведена
повертається до концертного залу.
Але до якого концертного залу:
турбінний зал електростанції в Пенемюнде,
експериментальної станції армії Вермахту.
Тут нацисти розробляли і
випробовували балістичні ракети,
тут помирали підневільні працівники.
Сьогодні це місце - музей і
вже 20 років простір для музики.
І якої музики!
«Концерт для оркестру» Бела Бартока,
мабуть, його найвідоміший твір.
У 1943 році Барток виїхав до США,
втікаючи від нацистського режиму.
«класична музика»
Моя сім’я дуже постраждала від війни
й перебування тут, на Узедомі
викликає багато сумних спогадів,
але я щасливий, що місце з такою жахливою історією
перетворилося на місце,
де ми можемо створювати музику.
А музика заліковує рани.
Друга яскрава подія на Пенемюнде -
концерт для скрипки з оркестром «Анн-Софі»
у виконанні Анни-Софі Муттер, написаний для
неї покійним чоловіком Андре Превіном.
Він теж був змушений
тікати від режиму нацистів до США.
Музика - це завжди спроба відродити мову,
якій тисячі років.
Проте вона також має й власну історію.
«класична музика»
Музика не має меж, вона поєднує
зовсім різне між собою.
Навіть якщо це звучить дивно,
Ви побачите, вона нікого не залишить байдужим.
«класична музика»
Жінка-віртуоз, яка доторкнулася до струн душі
кожного присутнього в залі та оркестр,
який зумів повернутися на сцену.
До речі, вони пробудуть на острові до вівторка.
Ця музика торкнулася й струн моєї душі.
Зараз з'ясуємо, про що говоритимемо
наступного тижня.
Традиційний огляд новин у неділю
у «heute journal aus:blick» від Йорга Білла.
Канцлер Німеччини з візитом до Африки.
До середи Олаф Шольц побуває в Сенегалі,
Південно-Африканській Республіці та Нігері.
У Нігері у межах навчальної місії
перебувають німецькі солдати.
Останнім часом внутрішня напруга
в країні Західної Африки посилилася.﻿
У середу десятки тисяч вірян
розпочнуть паломництво до Штутґарту,
де відбудеться 102-ге зібрання католицьких мирян.
Цьогоріч гасло звучить: «Жити в злагоді».
Є багато тем для обговорення, як-от:
церковні реформи, жертви сексуального насильства з боку духовенства
чи наслідки війни в Україні.
У четвер відбудеться церемонія нагородження
Міжнародною премією імені Карла Великого,
яку отримають Світлана Тихановська, Вероніка Цепкало
та Марія Колеснікова.
Жіноче тріо політичних активісток отримають
нагороду за мужню відданість боротьбі
з авторитарним режимом у Білорусі.
Наступної суботи увага футбольного світу
буде зосереджена на Парижі.
Там у фіналі Ліги чемпіонів
зустрінуться ФК «Реал Мадрид» та «Ліверпуль».
Для тренера «Ліверпуля» Юрґена Клоппа
це був би другий титул ﻿у цьому турнірі
після 2019 року.
Мегапротистояння можна дивитися
в прямому ефірі на каналі ZDF.
Поговоримо ще про проноз погоди.
Зранку на півночі і на сході буде сонячно,
на заході та півдні зливи та грози,
у другій половині дня та ввечері
місцями грози з сильним дощем,
великим градом та сильними шквалами.
Максимальна температура сягатиме 20°-28°.
У вівторок температура коливатиметься від 16° до 25°,
у середу та четвер очікуються зливи на півночі,
в інших регіонах температура 16°-24°.
Ми розпочали цей вечір
з погляду на наш великий світ.
Наскільки все пов'язано між собою,
наскільки невелика й уразлива наша планета,
можливо, стає по-справжньому зрозумілим
лише під час погляду з висоти.
Після повернення з МКС німецький астронавт
Маттіас Маурер
розповів, як це було, коли він дивився на Землю з космосу
і пролітав над Україною.
А тоді ти просто бачиш трохи світла там,
де знаходиться столиця,
і думаєш: там щось трапилося.
А якщо придивитися уважніше,
раптом видно такі маленькі спалахи світла
навколо столиці і тоді стає зрозуміло,
що це удари ракет.
З одного боку, ми так далеко
від людських проблем,
а з іншого боку ми настільки близькі,
що я бачу це нещастя, цей жах на власні очі
з висоти більш ніж 400 км і, звісно, ​​відчуваю це.
Таким був наш світ цієї неділі.
Завтра в ефірі чекайте на новини
з Марієттою Сломкою та Гайнцом Вольфом.
Бажаємо гарного вечора.
До побачення.